Where else do we want to go?
Let's go to the two oh two area code.
Haven't heard from the two oh two for a little
while.
Who's calling today from two oh two.
There's a solution.
Hey, Luciane, what's going on?
All right.
So you talked a lot of people talked about,
you know, if Biden gets elected.
Is Trump going to stay in the White House?
All that sort of stuff.
My question is.
Between the election and when the delegates
actually cast their ballots, which is a.
Process I'm not very familiar with.
Is there area there for tinkering by?
Any member of the Republican Party, state
governors, attorney generals, to sway thing,
to change some of the votes, because I know
some delegates don't necessarily have to vote
for.
Who the citizens have elected.
So I think you may be confusing to think it's
a good question, but let's first undo the
confusion.
You've got the nominating conventions, which
are based on delegates.
That is like the Republicans select their
nominee and the Democrats select their nominee.
What happens after the presidential is electors
are.
I believe it's on December 14th, but I'm not
totally sure where they go.
And they formally say from the state of Massachusetts,
you know, we give our however many electors
we have to Joe Biden or whatever the case
may be.
So were you a little confused about the two
of those because you were kind of mixing up
the language?
I just got the terminology wrong.
OK.
Got.
So.
So we're talking about the December electors,
right?
Yes.
OK.
So there is this thing called a faithless
elector.
And the idea is that if you have a situation
like we had in 2016 where the public elects
a lunatic who's completely in over his head
and unfit for the job, there is a mechanism
that would give the electors leeway to become
faithless, meaning they lose faith in the
way that their state voted and to select a
different person.
And there were rumors and even some claims
in 2016 that it was going to happen and they
weren't going to vote for Trump.
And it didn't happen.
Obviously, Donald Trump got his electors and
he became president.
So is there the possibility that an attorney
general, a governor or someone could get to
the electors and try to strong arm or coat?
Yeah, it's it's all possible.
I don't think it's going to happen.
And is due, the electors have to give all
the electoral votes or are they broken up,
like if there's 13 electoral votes, they could
get it.
They can throw one the other way.
Yeah, it's 13.
So if they're if if a status 13 electoral
votes, there's 13 electors in, each one would
get a vote.
OK.
Yes.
All right, my friend.
Thank you.
Great to hear from you.
A lot of a lot of good calls this week.
I must say.